في ايران يبدو ان حل شرطه الاخلاق لم يحل
من عزم المتظاهرين على الاكمال بما بداوه
منذ اكثر من شهرين فبوصلته المحتجين هي حل
النظام لا حلوا شرطه الاخلاق دعوات
الاضراب هذه تزيد من مخاوف السلطات
الايرانيه بعد ان ادى الدعوات مماثله
لتعبئه المحتاجين في الاسابيع الماضيه الى
زياده الاحتقان الشعبي بحسب صحيفه
الجاردينيا واليوم تجددت الاحتجاجات في
مختلف المدن الايرانيه لتشمل نحو 80
بالمئه من الاسواق والبازارات الى جانب
المصانع مع تجدد كل اضراب لا تتغير اساليب
النظام الايراني اذكد الحرس الثوري ان
القوات الامن لن ترحم ما اسمتهم بمديريه
الشغب وقطاع الطرق والارهابيين وفقا ما
نقلته وكالته تسنيم الايرانيه كما نقلت
ايران انترناشونال عن رئيس السلطه
القضائيه بولام حسين قوله ان بعض
المتظاهرين ادينوا بتهمه الحرابه التي
يترتب عليها حكم
شو الاخبار
اه
[تصفيق]